if you want to hear my theory on how a
couple familiar characters might have
played a hand in the ending of Annabelle
comes home then stick around to the end
of this video it's been a long journey
spanning over several movies but
Annabelle is finally coming home today
on things he missed I'm covering the
third movie of the Annabelle subset
Annabelle comes home and it starts with
the nurses again we've seen this exact
conversation included in the conjuring
Annabelle and now Annabelle comes home
at least this time we get to see what
happens after that ed takes the doll as
he and Lorraine began a long drive home
Lorraine says that they might get lost
and she'll wake up in California that
could be a reference to the fact that
the Annabelle doll is in California in
the last movie chronologically or maybe
a clue that he'll be headed there in the
future the car breaks down near a
cemetery and EDD hops out to inspect it
Lorraine hears a voice say I like your
dog Annabelle Higgins also known as
Janice says this exact line when
breaking into John and Mia's house in
animal
one of the things I'll be talking about
in this video is how the demon that's
attached to the Annabelle doll learns
new tricks from each home that he stays
in imitating the Higgins adopted
daughter is just one of them as the
pastor from the conjuring helps ed and
Lorraine secure the doll a number of
supernatural occurrences take place one
of which is the clocks moving backwards
much later in the film a character named
Danielle sees a TV screen that shows a
feat of her a couple seconds into the
future so I'm thinking that time
manipulation could be a new ability that
the demon Malthus has picked up this may
or may not be related to Lorraine's
ability to see past and future events as
showcased in the conjuring - or the TV
that seems to show programs related to
what's about to happen in the original
Annabelle
Judy's babysitter Mary Ellen goes to the
grocery store to prepare a cake for her
birthday and at the end of one of the
aisles there's a comic book display with
four covers that we can see Swamp Thing
the demon detective comics and Batman
the demon is obviously there because the
antagonists of the conjuring universe
are demons but another interesting note
is that all four comics are DC James Wan
who directed the conjuring one and two
and David F Sandberg who as you know
directed Annabel creation both went on
to make DC comic book movies I haven't
seen these movies but I have heard that
they sometimes link back with an Annabel
reference Mary Ellen's friend Daniella
shows up at the house and finds a bell
and she asked if this is a spirit Bell
when the spirits are Unleashed later all
the bells ring like crazy this is one of
those tricks that mouth has picked up
over the years in Annabel creation
Esther Mullins is bedridden and uses a
similar bell to request help which the
demon takes advantage of to scare these
two girls
when Daniela sneaks into the Warren
artifact room for the first time
everything that will come to know about
the lore of this movie is set up outside
of Malthus there are at the very least
three other spirits from the Warren's
past cases that are set free Daniela
touches the book on the black shuck
which if you don't know is the legend of
a ghostly black dog that could be found
in the UK some have said that it's a
demon and others have said that it's an
omen of death it's not clear if the book
is the artifact in this case or if it's
the taxidermy dog seen in the background
but I'm guessing it's the book because
that's what she touches in the study
later when they're snooping into the
case files it refers to the black shuck
is a hellhound from st. Mary's Cemetery
in England later we see the box that the
info from this case is kept in and the
label says February 1966 which predates
both the conjuring and Annabelle another
object that she touches is the bag of
coins the case file we see later for
this case is called the ferryman okay I
was kidding when I said they should make
a conjuring movie on the Tooth Fairy but
it turns out they've gone ahead and
pulled it off
this one is an ancient Greek legend
about the mythological Karen said to
fairy the souls of the dead away from
the land of the living the coins seen
over the eyes of the victims are a
reference to Karen's Obul and it was
seen as a bribe for him to carry over
the soul and prevent it from drifting
back to the world of the living
when Daniela later invades the case file
for this she shares the picture of a
victim that looks like Mary Ellen saying
they could be sisters this is the
doppelganger like women in the coffin
that Mary Ellen must pride the Annabelle
doll away from at the end of the movie
then there's the wedding dress and
though it's not said my name in
Annabelle comes home it's based on the
legend the Haunted wedding dress of Anna
Baker this is a legend about a girl from
the 1940s who met a bitter and miserable
death after her father didn't allow her
to marry the man who'd she'd fallen in
love whoa Judi explains that this dress
Hans people and causes them to become
violent which is what happens later that
night to Daniela after the ghost of the
bride pins her and does that throw up
black substance in her mouth thing the
same thing that got Janice possessed in
Hannah Bell creation
so other than Malthus those are the
three main evil spirits that get
released in Annabelle comes home but
there are a few others that I believe
got out as well some of which you may
find familiar once malthus is out bad
things start to happen that afternoon
someone knocks on the door and Mary
Ellen opens it to find that it's be the
deceased daughter of mr. and mrs.
Mullins from Hannah Bell creation and
the form that the demon uses to trick
them later
one of the notes left for the girls says
miss me later on when Daniela is back in
the artifacts room the typewriter says
miss me over and over the idea of
leaving notes behind comes from B who
used to leave her dad notes when she
wanted to play hide and seek and the
phrase miss me is something that the
demon used to terrorize the nurses from
the opening of the Kandra the scene
where Judi is attacked by the
wedding-dress woman in her room in the
February ascent of a scene from the nun
where the demon circles around the
outside of the room that appears and
charges forward whenever she walks by a
picture frame she causes it to fall but
when she walks by the cross it flips
over into a satanic cross later on if
you pay attention to the game show on
the TV the contestant is a young girl
who wins a Raggedy Ann doll so the
actual doll that the Annabelle doll is
based on continues the streak of
appearing as an easter egg in each movie
that night after Judy is in bed Daniela
heads home but realizes that she still
has the keys to the warrens artifact
room so she sneaks back in to try to
contact her father one more time
she thinks she's made contact but it's
really just the demon posing as her
father to scare her when it comes and
screams at her the form of her dad is
missing one eye perhaps another trick
that mouth has picked up from Esther
Mullins that he adds to his arsenal
meanwhile Mary Ellen pours herself a
glass of milk which the demon promptly
destroys we get it dude you don't like
skim the ferryman also starts to torment
her by rolling a bunch of coins at her
wow man I wish my demons give me free
money but things get real when she sees
the two coins near the ceiling in the
dark because anyone who's seen the
original Annabelle may know that this is
how Malthus sneaks up on you by climbing
on the ceiling and then pouncing down
this is about when the air heating
begins Mary Ellen gets air heated across
the floor downstairs and Judy is fast
asleep upstairs before I mentioned that
there may be another familiar spirit
that gets released from the artifact
room because the way that Judy gets
pulled down in her bed is very
reminiscent of the attacks issued by
Bathsheba the witch that the warns
defeat in the conjuring but that isn't
all because the music box that Bathsheba
is stored in appears in the climax scene
in the study where he can be seen
sitting in the background before somehow
appearing back in the artifact room at
the end of the movie but back to Judy's
room for a moment the light projector is
knocked down and four shadows appear on
the wall one for each color of light the
first is the shape of the Annabelle doll
then B then the adult Annabelle Higgins
and the last one is Malthus which is the
first that we see of him in his true
form during this movie as I mentioned
Malthus has picked up some alternate
forms and tricks along the way from the
farmhouse and Annabelle creation to the
apartment and Hanna belt and the nurses
home in the conjuring but apparently
he's also been to the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter because he tries to suck
out Judy's soul through her face which
is exactly how the Dementors suck your
soul out in Harry Potter together the
three girls are able to contain the evil
once again but before I end this video I
have one more lingering question that
I'd like to answer the whole idea of
this movie is that judy has this young
babysitter that makes the mistake of
letting a friend open up the artefact
room but what happened to Judy's
grandmother that stays over and takes
care of her in the conjuring know we
know Annabelle comes home takes place
between the conjuring and the Condren
too because the music box that they
acquired at the end of the first one is
there on the shelf but the toy that they
acquired from the conjuring too isn't
there yet actually it doesn't 100% make
sense because the scene takes place in
68 so I think the one year later text
and Annabelle comes home just means one
year after the conjuring so Annabelle
comes home must take place in 19
1 or 1972 so what happened to Georgiana
in that one year it's possible they just
fired her after this whole incident took
place
but I like to think that they're still
in good terms Georgiana was getting up
there in age and it's possible that she
could have passed on maybe her ghost is
still present in the house it's never
explained in Annabelle comes home what
caused Judy to overcome her fear of
ghosts giving her the courage to follow
the spirit of father Michael Morrissey
that's the guy that she sees at her
school in order to recover the key and
get back the Annabelle doll but she does
reiterate a line that Mary Ellen had
told her earlier maybe not all ghosts
are bad I like to think that she may
have realized this by encountering or
remembering Georgiana's ghost somewhere
along the way that wraps up this trilogy
of things you missed in Annabelle book
click the post on the left to see my
other conjuring Universe episodes and
we've got a new main line conjuring
movie on the way very soon so make sure
you're subscribed to seize these worlds
for new Horrors every week bring that
death belt for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]